banana fritters take your bananas
and to get them really nice and soft
just
rub the banana sip together flour
and baking powder sugar
into the flour
then add coconut for texture and a pinch
of salt
sounds strange in the dessert but it
works brilliantly especially
with the fritters makes the batter nice
and crisp start
crushing
and use the back of the fork and just
push it against the side of the bowl
and then once you've mixed that
through i'm gonna make that mix now
slightly fragrant
with some lime zest
now the lime just really
elevates the sort of richness and the
denseness of the banana
a couple of tim film so it doesn't get a
skin on top sit that in the fridge for
15 minutes
batter now is ready use a metal spoon to
drop the batter
to the bottom of the pan i mean they hit
that oil
they puff up that's why it's important
to put your spoon into the oil
so the mixture runs off and creates this
lovely little
fritter
and then gently fry get a slotted spoon
and nice and carefully turn them over
the smell of that lime is extraordinary
fry for two to three minutes as they
start floating
it signifies the fact that they're
cooked off with a gas
and just let them drain are those
beauties
lovely sprinkling when they're hot
with the sugar actually sticks to them
they're done ready to go gazpacho
for dessert sweet and refreshing
pineapple like you've never tasted
before
first job the gazpacho soup for me the
secret of a great gazpacho
is overripe tomatoes peppers cucumber
a little bit of heat with a garlic we've
got to leave it to marinade
first peppers cut around the flat edges
to minimize waste
[Music]
then chop the nice thing about
making the gazpacho there's no set
recipe
because you can put it together purely
all tomatoes
half peppers half tomatoes i like the
flavor of the cucumber in there as well
that gives it that freshness
the secret of a great gazpacho is the
longer you leave it marinating
the better the flavour so if you can get
this done the night before
and left in the fridge the results
are stunning the green and red peppers
have subtly complementary flavors
and go well with ripe tomatoes start off
by removing the bitter core get a little
knife
and just put it in where the core is and
twist it around
and you get this little core out i
remember my first experience
eating a gazpacho in spain
mind-blowing i've never forgotten that
quarter your tomatoes
keeping the juicy seeds that add so much
depth of taste
nice then from there cucumber
just peel that the seeds i'm gonna leave
in
that gives it the flavor and the texture
cucumber and gazpacho
does exactly what it does in a pims it
sort of freshens it up
and makes it mouth-watering slice that
in half
again into quarters and chop
now to give gazpacho its unique texture
and thicken the soup
bread and the crispy the crust the
better
then garlic thinly sliced
next spring onions nice and roughly
chopped
and basil stalks and all we can use
stalks and
basil stalks parsley stalks tarragon
stalks they have the most amazing flavor
basil in and now we're gonna start
marinating
salt black pepper and a good coating of
olive oil
this gives it a glossy creamy flavor
and the cherry vinegar that's the
perfect vinegar
for the gazpacho it's a strong acidic
complement to the flavors then just mix
it up
and the smell already is incredible it
doesn't look
like a gazpacho but by the time this
marinades
and all those flavors start getting to
know one another
all of a sudden you've got this huge
explosion
of contrast now
push that down in the restaurants we
press
the marinade down overnight a couple of
big pans on top and we crush
all the ingredients and then blitz it
the next day
flavor is extraordinary leave all those
fresh ingredients
packed with goodness to marinade from
half an hour to even overnight
and then when you blend it it just comes
together
like this sumptuous rich delicious
chilled soup
to go with my super tasty soup i've got
an ultra healthy
and exciting dessert carpaccio of
pineapple which is a chefy way of saying
super thinly sliced it's done with a
twist we're gonna have a delicious
flavoured salt has to be flavored with
vanilla
simply scrape out the vinegar seeds and
add to sea salt along with the pod to
store
now that basically keeps forever there's
no sale by date because it's salt
and vanilla so so fragrant so delicious
you don't need much of this fragrant
salt to intensify the sweetness of the
pineapple
pineapple sliced peeled pineapple into
wafer thin pieces
it's almost like nice little discs
slightly transparent
[Music]
once you've sliced the pineapple take
the flavor to another level
a light sprinkle of vanilla salt and
arrange the pineapple
in a flower shape
[Music]
it's a beautiful way of finishing a meal
the fragrance other than the crunch
with the salt and the vanilla salt just
marinades
the pineapple beautifully then scatter
nutrient rich pomegranate seeds over the
top
to finish finely shredded fresh mint
just
slice them really thin
and then give that nice cool
minty flavour pineapple
my carpaccio is ready and my gazpacho
has been marinating in the fridge
time to blend the soup
in
onto your blender and start off
nice and slowly blend until super fine
and gloriously silky
and serve refreshingly cold
get your bowl
and pour it in
now to finish it get some fresh basil
roll it nice and tight
and shred it and then drop it into your
bowl
fresh chopped basil and then finally
just a touch of extra virgin olive oil
just to give that
really nice additional freshness
and look at that healthy and delicious
gazpacho soup to me is a taste of
mediterranean sunshine in a bowl
followed by the wafer thin carpaccio of
pineapple with jewels of pomegranate
goodness for dessert
practically all of your five a day in
one incredible healthy lunch
you